so red pill week - the sort of meta
logistical thing this week would be
balancing story hive with you know
everything yeah no yeah it's it's been a
very interesting
the thing is dan and I are both
freelancers yeah so to speak so when we
submitted to story hive we couldn't just
stop our whole world and then say okay
our main project in life has to be story
hive that's just not doable in you know
the facet that we have to pay bills yeah
you can't and you can't assume that
you're going to get it right do you do
that you're gonna probably be
disappointed yes
Oh severely severely disappointed so
it's been interesting trying to balance
maintaining the work that needs to be
done for red pill and then also
everything else yeah cuz it's it's kind
of this switchover period like this
switchover that you've gotta do I mean
the the $10,000 grant is is enough that
we can that we can't afford to like not
take a job or two and I really know
barely know barely well I mean and it's
also bonus like assessing how much
$1,000 is you know we're not getting
we're not getting $10,000 it's you know
we're essentially getting paid for the
day that we shoot what are we all right
right like the this isn't a continuous
job that we're being paid for though the
ninety five percent of our budget will
be going towards other people helping us
and creating our you know our set
we're basically and this isn't even
until the end of it is the thing is
we're basically paying ourselves enough
to retroactively Lee cover the cost of
gasoline and food expenses basically our
expenses are covered as director and
producer expenses are covered
that's about it however we get our name
on that though we do get our name on
that oh yeah it's just really what the
benefit of all this is yeah
even ignoring the money aside from the
money the money aspect of it there is
still this rollover in just energy and
effort right that it's like okay well
now you're you're adding this in and
it's like it's this period like for me
in particular this last week has been a
lot of okay take things that were
already on my plate and wrap them up and
get them kind of out of the way so that
more time can be focused into into a red
pill particularly like the more
front-loaded stuff so I still need to
get the animatic done and I need to
finalize the script and then we're
hiring crew we're hiring crew so yeah
that's what I've been kind of doing for
the last week is just a lot of
Correspondence so we're getting crew
settled right now all of which have been
attached to the program or project um
but we still don't have word back from
our studio space yeah so it's kind of
like are you interested and would you be
available in a generic amount of time if
we gave you a heads up yeah so we've had
a few people come back already and say
that yeah they're on board and they're
totally interested which is awesome
because they're people we work with and
they're our friends and we're super
pumped about that on top of that we're
also dealing with cast so I put out a
casting call so to speak and we've
gotten about 20 applicants so far so Dan
and I are gonna have to go and spend
some time probably next week and cipher
through the ones that we know we want to
have an actual audition with and music
I've been I've been in contact with a
couple a couple musicians one of whom is
a duo that contacted me I liked I liked
their demo reel they didn't quite have
anything that was
like nailed the the genre that they were
looking for but they had stuff across a
lot of different a lot of different
genres and so they do seem to be quite
flexible and I told them sort of the the
outline and they seemed up for it so you
know we'll be back before it there's a
lot of actually there's a lot of
diplomacy in this stage where you know
you you're trying to convince people to
do something for you but at the same
time it's like you they're trying to you
know sort of it's like what are they
going to get out of it and when you're
gonna get out and how can you arrive at
a really good you know respectful and
mutually beneficial beneficial
arrangement and you know and in dealing
with that like there's this is actually
been a really good good time for this
because it's a good chance to sort of go
adult with the way that you end up so
one of the big problems that ends up
coming up when you're working on stuff
for absolutely zero budget when
everybody is just your friend that
you've roped in is that there's there's
a lack of room to really maneuver with
that yes you know they're your pals you
can't just be like yo dick we hired you
know like yeah or that it's like that
particularly if if someone you know
who's a friend or an acquaintance you
know is has a creative skill that you
can't quite cover yeah like they're a
musician and they're like hey I made
this for you for your project
and it's like well it doesn't quite like
and you look at it and you go like I
like you but this either a isn't very
good or B just doesn't fit right you
know how do you handle that how do you
handle that yeah and so it's it's really
good to kind of be in a environment
where you know you can talk to people as
fellow professionals as fellow creators
and just sort of say this like hey maybe
just because you
contact me doesn't mean that your best
for the thing and I've had people I've
had this happen before where people have
called me up and they're like hey we
want you to do this thing and I've just
had to tell them it's like that's not in
my wheelhouse
yeah Oh totally yeah you know and having
that expectation set out in front of you
can get you into trouble too
yeah so it's it's trying to have that
balance and I think would the other
thing to really mention is that when we
sat down even pre applying to story hive
we said if we had a crew we would pay
them yeah that was that was our big that
was sort of our first thing was that
we're paying crew because all too often
what ends up happening with grant
projects and low-budget projects is crew
ends up coming it's like everyone wants
to pay their crew but they still end up
paying their crew last right and it's
like it's like oh well the the the cream
of the money the tie like the the first
right off the top is like all right
camera rental all right you know gear
all right location all right actor then
you know it's like and by the time
you're getting down to cruise like oh
well we've only got a hundred bucks per
person and it's gonna be a 12-hour day I
hope you're okay with making eight bucks
an hour right
it sucks by the way we both know this
yeah you know and it's like so so we
really wanted to kind of kind of reverse
that and we sat down like what we were
going to going to pay people first and
then it was like okay well now can we
afford a read no can we afford an fs7
maybe can't we afford her so maybe so
it's like you know the suddenly the
camera comes guess it gets knocked down
because you're you and the thing is is
that and a lot of a lot of people think
that well that kind of front you know
very front end kind of equipment rental
is going to be the thing that makes the
bigger difference but right I think at
the end of the day talented crew it's
it's not always in the most obvious ways
but talented crew is going to have a
bigger impact
than just bringing your camera Oh top
notch yeah well the other thing too is
what a lot of people don't see of course
is making the film right so the
experience of the people actually
creating it you know in the moment on
the day of shooting actually affects a
lot of the area and how things are
working you know if you have an actor
who doesn't know where they're supposed
to be or isn't used to the rhythm
alright you being on set then you're
gonna have that performance affected by
that oh the worst is when you get an
actor who like you know they might be
quite talented at stage but they're not
used to acting around a camera and so
they look in the lens yeah all the time
and it's like you can't do that yeah
we're in a kind of a weird phase right
now because there's a lot of uncertainty
still because our location is such a key
component to understanding like where we
go from here and but we're on the other
side of things like we have people
already locked in or locked in you know
and it's kind of like I just want us to
be three weeks from now yeah I want us
to be I was really hoping that that
phone call would come yesterday yeah but
it didn't so so we don't know so we're
still we're still location is up in the
air and that's you know yeah basically
I'm putting the producer pants on next
week and I'm giving them to the end of
day Monday because they did say that
they would need a week to find out yeah
whether or not the studio space would be
available so Monday if I don't hear from
them Tuesday morning they will be
getting a column from me and that's fair
but no my confident pants because if I
don't put the confident pants on I won't
have none button it up to the top top
level Oh top button top button button so
aside from the general and and regular I
mean the the I think the thing that I
want to drive home is that this kind of
early uncertainty is very normal
sure it's not it's not worrisome yet
it it might get terrifying down the road
but right now it's just kind of it
creates a little bit of anxiety but I
think everything does though these these
projects do have like once once the
bigger things start falling into place
or start start firming up then suddenly
everything does yeah so it's like once
location is locked or like I shouldn't
say once location lock once we're
comfortable that we have a place to
actually build this and we have a time
booked in order to do that yeah
then suddenly we can call up all of our
crew and be like yo January 16th right
you know mark or tentative mark it down
you know you know yeah like that's it's
like that's the day we've got the studio
that's the day and you know you can go
down the you know you can go down the
list and say part of the reason why we
haven't I'm not really firming anything
up with musicians yet is because well
what's going to be the timeline on that
exactly yeah and that's the thing we
don't know we have no idea right now
because if we end up doing like if we
end up shooting mid late January well
then it's like put a lot more maybe do
the music a lot sooner right and like
get a lot more work done on it whereas
if we're shooting super early January
like we're shooting on that if we get
that New Year's Day slot yeah
then well all of a sudden you've got a
month right to to do pose which would be
comfortable that's a comfortable that's
nice very comfortable
yeah so the producer in me the very
unexperienced producer in me this is you
know is it you can't I think the one
advice someone ever gave me about that
kind of uncertainty is you can't think
oh it's January 16th already because if
you do that then you're just gonna freak
out and you're gonna be like nothing's
gonna get done everything's gonna be a
mess and we can't move forward so I'm
trying to really focus on okay I have a
little list at home and it's just like
who have you emailed how they responded
and you know what what are the next
steps that you need to do and I'm trying
to really keep that in a like a
chronological order so that I can keep
focused on that so team power so we're
excited we're nervous we're very much
enjoying enjoying the experience but
we're making things happen and next week
it'll be I think very interesting yes
next next week next we think should if
things haven't started solidifying then
we'll probably a lot more panicked by
the time like December 15th rolls around
but we're probably yeah all right so
there's there's this week's update if
anything super big happens then we'll
make sure to take the camera along for
that but otherwise if it's just kind of
going through going through the routine
then expect another vlog next week
mm-hmm thank you everyone for for your
support thank you for your votes and
thanks for watching high five high five